-Welcome back to the show, Al.
How are you?
-I'm doing great.
How are you doing?
-I'm doing well.
I can't help but start
by mentioning the fact that when
you were on the show in November
in the studio, it was
the middle of impeachment,
and you were saying
it was as dangerous a time
as we've lived through,
and yet it seems
incredibly quaint now.
This does seem to be a pattern
that every time
we think that things
are really bad,
they unfortunately get worse
How are you feeling right now?
-[ Laughs ]
Well, yeah.
It's a scary time in many ways
because everybody,
whether you're a Republica
or Democratic or Independent
or something else --
just about every single grou
is feeling
that there's nobody
really in charge,
or at least not in charge
in a positive way.
And back when we talked before
that's exactly the time period
when the country should have
been moving full speed ahead
to make preparations
for the pandemic
about which we had
already been warned.
-You weren't necessarily warne
during the Clinton-Gore
administration,
but you were prepared.
Um, I've read that
President Clinton
had read a book
about biological warfare
and took it seriously,
and you did begin
stockpiling medicine.
You did begin
stockpiling vaccines.
How hard is it to watch
an administration
that does not take this
seriously as a threat?
-Well, it's hard.
Of course, it's much harde
to watch and listen
to the families
that have gone through
such horrific experiences,
and I won't recap them here.
We've all been
going through that,
vicariously, for most,
thankfully.
But it's hard. Yes.
And, um, you know,
it's connected to climate
in this sense.
The scientists who warned us
about the pandemic
included the very best
epidemiologists and virologist
in the world,
and they warned us
to prepare for a pandemic
that was almost exactly like
the one that
we're struggling with now.
So when we hear
the climate scientists
arguing for even longer
that we need to do
something to stop
the onrushing climate crisis
the lesson seems clearly tha
it's best to listen to them.
One other thing
they have in common --
both the COVID-19 pandemic
and the climate crisis
hit the communities of color
and the poorest Americans
first and hardest
and, in that process,
reveal the really stark
and incredible inequities
and injustices
that have been allowed to go o
for way, way too long.
We got to do something about it.
-Certainly in parts of the
United States and worldwide,
it does seem like government
are taking this very seriously
It does seem like
we are mobilizing
against police brutality
in a way that we maybe
haven't ever before.
Does that give you confidenc
that we can do the same
for climate?
-I really believe, Seth,
that we are witnessing
a kind of general awakening.
I don't think
these things compete.
I don't think it's, you know
a zero-sum situation,
where the more attention
paid to the pandemic,
the less attention paid
to these other things.
I think, for example,
about the gains made
by the LGBTQ community
over the last decade or so
Those gains are not going away
They're being consolidated
We just had a significant
Supreme Court victory
consolidating them.
Gender equity gains
of the last several years,
they're being consolidated
And I think that this awakenin
has touched people
in cities all around the world
after the heinous
George Floyd murder.
It was such a horrible event
and such a cue for people
to take off whatever blinder
they had on
to see and understand
the incredible injustice
that we have allowed to persis
for so long.
And, by the way,
the burning of fossil fuels,
which creates the global-warming
pollution mainly,
also creates the air pollution
that elevates the death rate
under COVID-19.
There have been multiple studies
showing that communities
and counties
that have more air pollution
from burning fossil fuels
have a significantly highe
death rate from the pandemic
That's true in other countries
as well.
So we need to -- we need to pu
the Black Lives Matter agend
in the center of the plans
now being developed
for a green recovery.
We need a just transition
so that those who are likely
to suffer economically
if we don't provide them
with better jobs
in this transition
are taken care of.